moscow says it will increase missile
attacks on kiev the warning follows
unverified russian claims that ukraine
carried out airstrikes on villages in
russian territory and sank russia's
largest warships in the blank sea in the
black sea we're now getting reports of
fatalities following russian strikes in
eastern ukraine as the war passes its
50th day air raid sirens have been
sounding across the country
days into the war and this is still the
wake up call in kiev
heavy explosions were heard here
overnight they're said to be the most
powerful since russian forces pulled out
of the region around the capital
says it will step up its attacks
tonight sea-based high-precision
long-range missiles hit a military
facility on the outskirts of kiev the
number and scale of missile strikes
against objects in kiev will increase in
response to any attacks of a terrorist
nature or sabotage on russian territory
by the kiev nationalist regime
some are asking if it's also in
retaliation for the sinking of this
warship the moskva russia's acknowledged
the ship has been lost but not that it
was due to ukrainian missiles either way
a big blow according to the pentagon
this is a cruiser they only have three
in this class and it's basically
designed for air defense that's uh
that's what this ship is designed to do
not unlike our own cruisers
so it's going to have an impact on their
capabilities certainly in the near term
but this footage from the southern port
city of mariupol serves as a reminder of
moscow's military might and brutality
with russia now focusing its attention
on ukraine's east mariupol would be key
in connecting the southern and eastern
fronts
despite a strong russian presence
ukraine says the city hasn't fallen yet
the country's president used his nightly
address to praise ukrainian resilience
to put it mildly no one was sure that we
would survive
everyone sympathized
many advised us to leave the
country advised us to actually surrender
to tyranny
but they didn't know us either
and they did not know how brave
ukrainians are
how much we value freedom
our opportunity to live the way we want
this war continues and ukrainians will
need to show even more of that bravery
if they're to repel the imminent russian
onslaught in the
east dw correspondent rebecca ritters is
in butcher which ukraine recently
recaptured from russian forces i asked
her about the situation there now
i'm here in that town that has now been
liberated
i want i mean it's definitely nothing
resembling normal phil here it's a ghost
town but uh one thing i was really
surprised by something that really
struck me was just the pace at which
everything has been cleared away you
know the world by now the world has
pretty much seen those horrific images
when peop
ukraine finally gained access to this
area again of all the tanks and the
debris and
stuff in that residential block that
everyone uh was seeing
all of that pretty much has now been
cleared it was really uh
quite surprising i was surprised i've
only been in kiev one day myself so i
didn't see any of it previously but
definitely everyone here just really
trying hard to get this city back on its
feet some of the people we spoke to
definitely telling me of the atrocities
that took place here and showing me
welcoming me into their homes which have
been all but destroyed one gentleman
whose house had been been used as a
russian headquarters and his house had
been completely destroyed the russians
blew it up before they left or just
after they left i suppose uh so it's
gonna take a very long time you'll see
behind me everything all the shops
completely still destroyed it's going to
take a very long time but people doing
what they can to get this back on its
feet
and and how are authorities going about
gathering evidence
yeah well that is the next step i mean
at the moment authorities are working
hard to gather evidence of war crimes so
far the human rights commission of
ukraine as of today has over 6 000
documented cases um authorities
definitely going through to talk to
people hundreds if not thousands of
journalists as well have been through
and spoken to people uh organizations
such as human rights watch and and the
like um that is sort of the next phase
at the moment here also so much is being
concentrated on the humanitarian effort
i mean the city is still cut off from
power and water
and telecommunications have been
restored now but obviously that is the
first step and then of course comes the
documentation of of all the war crimes
yesterday i was speaking to the
commissioner or the ombudsman rather for
the human rights commission and she was
saying they've also set up hotlines so
that people can report she said that was
really important particularly in the
cases of the sexual violence claims
because many people were still terrified
and traumatized and found it very
difficult to come forward so there are
hotlines also set up to be able to take
testimony
russian forces are now now seem to be
focusing their attention on the east of
the country um bring us up to data with
what's happening there
well that's right uh heavy bombardment
or refocus of russian efforts is
expected really any day now in the east
uh so obviously for the last week or so
authorities have been telling residents
to just get out of that area while they
still can
i was reporting from down near near that
area on the region bordering donbass on
the weekend spoke to lots of people from
luhansk donates those areas in the
donbass mass evacuations going on from
the east and the south but not everybody
is leaving of course as of the other day
still around about 30 percent of people
were staying in luhansk i actually spoke
to a gentleman at the train station when
i was leaving that area and he he was
leaving too but he was telling me uh
about some friends of his in lahars that
simply didn't want to leave they were
going to stick around and try and defend
they said they've lost everything
already in 2014 they weren't prepared to
do it again and he broke down in tears
as he was telling me the story obviously
the scenes that you just saw in that
report there from mario paul the scenes
that we've seen here from places such as
butcher everyone worried that we're
going to see similar scenes like that
down in the east
that's rebecca written in butcher well
ukraine's plight has prompted offers of
help from around the world but when
asked what they need most the answer
from the ukrainian leadership is always
the same
let's get more on this from liam collins
he's a retired u.s special forces
colonel and has been a military adviser
to ukraine he's now executive director
of the madison policy forum and joins us
from west point in the united states so
welcome to dw um all these weapons are
pouring into ukraine but how long is it
is it going to take for them to become
useful for ukrainian soldiers to be
trained and able to use them to good
effect
it really depends on the weapon system
and what the capability is for example
the list of most recent aid to ukraine
included what i saw from the us mi-17
helicopters which are russian
helicopters that their pilots are more
than capable of flying
so that's something they can integrate
right away javelin weapon systems we
started giving those in january of uh
2018 so again that's a weapon you can
disseminate and immediately employ the
switchblade uh drones you just spoke
about those we've been training them on
for the last few weeks and so we have a
cadre that's trained but obviously not
everybody out in the field so that will
take time so it really depends on the
specific weapon system and what the
training time is right and so it looks
like ukraine is not going to be short of
hardware supplies how is it doing in
terms of actual troops to operate these
weapons
yeah i mean that really hasn't you know
seen a lot of news on that in terms of
what losses they've taken i mean it's
they're fighting overwhelming combat
power by the russians and they're slowly
getting attributed so we have to
constantly place those weapon systems
the ammunition that they're that they're
exhausting uh but right the the fighters
are gonna be harder to replace but they
do have tens of thousands of right
volunteers in their territorial defense
force uh that that can supplement that
effort so
it looks like they've been able to
maintain that manpower for the time
being um and they just got to continue
to do that
and what are you hearing about how
russia is doing in terms of rearming and
putting itself in a position to keep up
this pressure we do hear a lot about
their hardware being defective and badly
maintained but they do seem to be in a
bind they've got millions of dollars
coming in every day from gas exports but
sanctions mean a dwindling number of
sources of technology to maintain and
replenish their hardware
i mean for the most part right those gas
exports and those sanctions those are
more longer-term effects they're not
going to affect the immediate
warfighting capability uh it's really
russia has a large amount stockpiled so
it's just getting those stockpiles to
the fight and as you said some are
dilapidated they haven't been maintained
some of those weapon systems they don't
have a good logistical support system
and we've seen throughout this war and
so now they're right trying to
reposition troops that have already been
uh you know some have been beat down
pretty badly up up in kiev and harkee
and they're trying to reposition them to
the east so it's it's gonna be uh you
know a challenge to put good uh capable
units uh into the fight on the east that
haven't taken uh significant action
already
let's talk about uh this because we have
this is what we've been hearing now that
that russia is preparing to go again at
ukraine uh ukraine's east and south how
do you see that panning out
yeah i mean obviously
putin's trying to salvage some kind of
victory and he knows he can't get it up
in the north so he's trying to
consolidate his forces and see what he
can pull out of this and and so i expect
to see it play out similar to what we've
seen to date right you've got the
overwhelming combat power of russia
against a much more tactically competent
uh ukrainian armed forces right that has
good leaders well-trained professional
forces that are going to beat them in
the tactical fight so it's just a matter
of can russia a trip uh you know the
more capable force to a great enough
level to attack allow him to achieve
victory or can ukraine continue to hold
off you know the the russian horde with
smart smartly time you know good
defenses and and smart time counter
attacks that they can do it to their
advantage
and a brief word about mario paul
how bad a loss would it be if uh for
ukraine if were russia to take that uh
port city
yeah i mean it's not a strategic
capability i mean
in not not in times of war right it's a
key trading port they need it for that
capability but i mean they haven't had
that since the war began and so it yeah
i mean
we heard about the bridge between uh uh
crimea and the east but it's it's not as
strategic as people are making it out to
be ukraine cannot right initially right
defended all their territory they were
going to take losses early in the war in
terms of territory that they have to
fight back as they did up in the north
and kiev and harkee so that's what i
would expect to see there and and russia
still despite his efforts down there has
not been able to take control of it at
this point okay good talking to you
thank you so much for joining us colonel
liam collins from the madison policy
forum